Good morning, everyone.
If you're on the
Zoom meeting, can you hear me?
All right.
I think it's time to get started.
My poor computer is struggling with uh
keeping up with Slack and Zoom and OBS
and the Twitch mod window. So, we'll see
how well this works.
All right. So, welcome to day two of
distributed systems. Uh last time we
only did logistics and administrativia
and stuff like that. Uh today we're
actually going to get to the to the
course content. So, uh so the first
thing I want to talk about is
what exactly are distributed systems?
So,
so this is this is going to be a
question that we try to answer as a
group. What is a distributed system?
So, I want to give one answer, which is
uh actually a funny answer from Leslie
Lamport, who is sometimes thought of as
the father of distributed systems. Uh
he's done a lot of the of the
foundational work in distributed systems
and we'll we'll talk about some of that
soon. Uh but Leslie Lamport said,
"A distributed system is a system where
I can't get my work done because some
computer that I've never even heard of
has crashed."
And he was kidding when he said that,
but there's actually a lot of truth to
that because
uh
um uh let me pause for a second because
folks aren't seeing the document camera
on Zoom.
I'll share it also.
Cool. So, you should now be seeing the
document camera
on Zoom.
Thanks for pointing that out.
All right. So,
Lamport's definition of distributed
systems, which was a a joke, uh actually
ends up having a lot of truth to it uh
because it's about uh
failure. And as we'll see, distributed
systems are uh uh characterized by
failure.
So, I want to give a definition that's
that's slightly more serious.
Um and this one comes from uh a guy
named Martin Kleppmann, who uh he's he's
the author of a book called Designing
Data-Intensive Systems. And uh if you
happen to look at the the course
website, uh
there's a there's actually a nice uh
illustration on the the course website
uh
which was which was created by him. Uh
and um
he he uh
uh
defines a distributed system this way.
So, this is this is Martin Kleppmann's
definition.
So, a distributed system is running on
several nodes
and you can just think of node as
meaning a computer
connected by a network.
And then the other key part of this is
that
it's characterized
by partial failures.
So, what do we mean by partial failures?
So, what I mean by it is that
some parts of the system might be
broken, while other parts of it are
okay.
Uh and furthermore, it's often
impossible, it's at least impossible for
the software to know what exactly is
broken.
So, what do I mean by impossible for the
software to know? Well, we'll come back
to that.
Um
so, to get a little bit more specific
about what I what I mean by nodes here,
um so I said you can just think of a
node as being a computer.
Uh but maybe a more formal way to define
it is we'll we can say that a node is an
instance of some software running on a
computer uh that communicates with other
nodes, which are also instances of
software running on some computer,
in order to accomplish some task.
So,
there's some things that students kind
of brought up in the past uh
when I asked this question about what is
a distributed system. Um and the things
the things that they brought up were
like things like oh, a system where work
is distributed fairly or multiple
computers behaving as a single computer.
And and these are good answers, but
they're also I think very optimistic,
right? Like uh okay, like ideally you
want the work to to be distributed
fairly, right? And ideally you might
want multiple computers to behave as
though they're a single computer.
Uh but um
in practice, distributed systems are
kind of rife with failure. And so, I
like the fact that uh that this
definition uh kind of makes brings
failure to the forefront.
So,
let's try to go into a little bit more
detail about what this partial failures
thing is about. Um so,
if you want to answer a question, you
can do so either in chat um or you can
do so if you're in the Zoom meeting, uh
you can do so by voice. Uh I ask that
you please keep yourself muted uh unless
you're talking.
Uh
so, um
actually, does anybody want to take a
stab at this? Um
like like what what would be an example
of a partial failure? What what do you
think that I mean by that?
Sure, okay. Ha. So, yeah, so there's a
couple of different things that people
are suggesting. So, um network
partition. Yeah, we're going to talk
more about this soon. Uh so, if you have
a network of machines,
different kinds of failures can can
occur, right? Like one kind of failure
is just one of those machines crashing.
But it's also possible that you could
have a failure even without any machines
crashing because the connections between
the machines fail.
So, that's one possibility.
Uh some other people are suggesting uh
the machines themselves crashing, right?
A a drive failure,
uh a physical failure of the machine.
Uh some other people are suggesting some
more uh
um
uh
intermittent failures like particular
messages being dropped.
Uh so,
I think the thing to keep in mind is and
and then also software misbehavior. So,
we'll talk more about that soon. Um so,
I think the thing to keep in mind is
that by partial failure, we mean that
some of the things there's the supposed
to be part of a computation happen
and others don't.
So, this is different from the kind of
failures that we're often used to
thinking about uh with a single machine.
So, on a single machine,
uh
often if part of, let's say, the
operating system fails, then it all
fails. So, that's what a kernel panic
is.
Uh and
the way that the system is designed is
so that
if part of the OS fails, right? Then it
will kernel panic and you'll have to
restart, right? There's no uh there's no
way to kind of continue to operate in
the presence of that kind of failure.
So,
treating
this kind of the this kind of partial
failure uh
as a as a as a situation where you have
to kind of keep going in the the
presence of a failure, um this becomes
more important when you have many
machines, right? If you have just one
machine, right? And something fails,
then
it's not so bad to have to just restart,
right?
So,
but if you have let's say that you have
four machines or 400,000 machines. And
let's say one machine fails. Well,
you don't want to have to take all of
the machines down and start the system
over completely in the case of one of
those four or one of those 400,000
machines failing. You really want the
rest to be able to keep operating in in
the event of such a failure. And in
fact, the more machines that you have,
the more inevitable it's going to be
that some machine is going to fail. So,
if you didn't allow the system to keep
running in the presence of partial
failures, then a system of of many many
hundreds of thousands of machines
uh wouldn't be would be completely
unusable, right? Because at that scale,
something is always going to be failing.
So, your system must continue to work in
the presence of failure uh because
otherwise, it would never work at all.
So, the probability is pretty high that
something is broken. So, if you failed
whenever something broke, then no work
would ever get done.
So, this philosophy of kind of
continuing to operate in the presence of
partial failure
um so I I I think of this is sort of the
cloud computing philosophy. So we can
kind of distinguish between
between different philosophies. So cloud
computing
versus
um
let's call it HPC or high performance
computing.
So the the HPC philosophy is more like
the philosophy of of choosing to treat
partial failure
as total failure.
So in the HPC philosophy
if something does fail
then you might start the computation
over completely from scratch. And
there's typically because failures are
common in a system of many machines
typically an approach is taken that
involves what's called checkpointing
which means every so often you save your
progress.
And then if a failure does occur
you roll back to wherever it is that you
that you checkpointed.
So that's one philosophy and those
systems are also considered distributed
systems.
But we're going to be spending more of
our time talking about this
the so-called cloud computing approach
which involves
uh
working around partial failures.
And expecting those kinds of failures.
Questions about this so far?
So let's start to talk about some
examples, right? Let's start to talk
about ways that failures can occur.
So as people have already pointed out in
addition to machines themselves failing
connections between them can fail,
right?
So so let's let's look at an example of
that. Let's say let's say that we have a
very very simple situation where you
where we have let's say two machines.
So let's say
we have a machine M1
and another machine M2.
And let's just say that M1 wants to ask
M2 a question and get a response.
So let's say that M1 wants to know what
the value of X is.
So M1 asks M2 hey what's the value of X?
And let's say M2 happens to know or
believe that X is five. So then
hopefully M2 would send back
five, right?
In this simple scenario where there's
two machines and there's one request and
one response
what are some of the things that could
go wrong? What do you think?
Message never sent. All right. So yeah,
so it's possible
that a message didn't get sent or just
gets lost somehow, right? So let's say
that so we'll say this.
If the request from M1 gets lost
why would it get lost? I don't know.
Maybe a backhoe took out the network
cable.
But for for one reason or another the
request from M1 could get lost, right?
um
So
then there's another possibility, right?
uh which is that this request from M1 is
just slow.
So you could have M1 ask, you know,
what's X?
And this message starts to get sent but
then
M2 is waiting and waiting
and never actually receives it.
Or it takes a long time for it to
receive it. M2 can't wait forever,
right? At some point it has to make a
decision, right? So
this slowness could happen for a number
of reasons.
It could happen
either in the network between M1 and M2
or it could also happen in some sort of
a message queue either on M1's side or
M2's M2's side.
But for what whatever reason maybe M1
thought that it sent the the the request
but then M2 never received it for
whatever reason.
Another possibility
right? Is it M2 crashed, right?
So M1 sent the message.
And let's say that the message even
actually arrived.
And then M2 immediately crashed.
So if that happened let's say that these
three let's say that any of these three
things happened.
Does M1 have any way of knowing the
difference between these three
situations?
No.
So from M1's point of view
none of these situations are really
distinguishable from one another even
though they're really quite different,
right? So the first situation you know
could be due to um
a backhoe taking out the network cable,
right?
The second situation could be due to
congestion on the network. The third
situation could just be
because M2 kernel panicked, right? It
could have nothing to do with the
network or it could be a lot of
different reasons. So but even though
even though all of these situations are
drastically different from one another
um
from M1's perspective of trying to to
understand and maybe from a human's
perspective on M1's side who's trying to
debug this problem
all these situations are are are totally
indistinguishable.
um
Here's another situation that's
indistinguishable.
Let's say that let's say that M2 doesn't
crash
um but let's say that
M1 sends the message
and M2 is just slow, right?
So in this case you know
maybe M2 has the answer but
but it's having trouble looking up the
answer because it has to go to disk or
something like that. So maybe M2 is just
being slow. Maybe maybe M2 is being
slower than M1 expected it to be and in
that case
maybe M1 decides that it's never going
to get a response from M2.
So so that's another issue. Or then
maybe M1 actually sends the response,
right?
But this time the message is slow.
And so M1 never actually gets the
response or the message gets lost.
So there's like a backhoe here
and it takes out the network cable
and then
and then our message gets lost.
So
all of these situations are completely
different, right? But
they
they all
basically look the same from M1's point
of view. So going going back to to the
first one again. So the the request in
the first place could get lost or the
request could just be really slow
or the machine that you're sending the
request to could have crashed
request to could be could be slow or the
response could be slow or the response
could get lost, right? So
from M1's point of view you can't tell
the difference between any of these
things.
um So so this is this is very important.
um
If you send a request to another node
and you don't receive a response it is
impossible to know why.
I'm actually going to write that down
because it's so important.
In particular, it's impossible to know
why without global knowledge of the
system.
Which you don't have.
So there's a bunch of horrible things
that can go wrong. Um
is there anything else that could go
wrong
in this in this M1 M2 scenario?
Sure. So okay. So M1 could crash in the
first place, right? I guess I guess if
M1 crashes then
uh
then that would be distinguishable on
M1's end from a situation in which
M1 doesn't crash.
Um
So some people have were were saying
things in chat a little while ago about
messages
becoming corrupted
or or cosmic rays flipping bits.
So so that's those are actually real
possibilities.
Uh or
M2 could lie, right? M2 could be a bad
actor and could refuse to answer the
question or could lie.
So so those sorts of things
like
M2 lying
refusing to answer
um
cosmic rays
those sorts of things
etc. Those are known as Byzantine
faults.
Uh and we'll talk about that a little
bit later in the course.
Uh a little bit.
So how do real systems deal with this
sort of situation?
Uh if one machine wants to send a
message to another machine
uh and it doesn't know for sure if it's
going to get a response.
Uh what is what does M1 do in practice
uh when it's when it's sending out a
request and it wants a response?
Okay, so some people are asking
questions like
um
Well, in this example we said that that
that M2's
knowledge of X is that it's five, right?
Um so
uh one person's question is well, what
if what if M1 asks for the answer,
right? And then M2 sends it and then it
changes soon after that. So yeah, that
would be yet another situation and that
so we're only talking about a
network of two machines, right? But
suppose that there were a third machine
out there M3
that also had the ability to send
messages to and from M2 and could update
the value of X.
So in that case sure the value that M1
gets might be stale by the time it gets
to M1.
So we're going to talk about that much
much more later in the course. That's
going to be one of the most important
issues that we discuss in fact.
So we'll talk about that but the the
kind of the point of this example is to
show that even even in this very simple
scenario where we only have two
machines, there's a whole lot of
uncertainty on on M1's end.
So
how do real systems deal with this? So I
would say
in reality what M1 has to do if it's
sending a message to another machine
is have some sort of timeout.
So so what's a timeout?
It's like a set amount of time before
you drop a request.
Right. Yeah, so for us it means
after some amount of time if M1 is is
sending this request, if there's no
response
give up and assume failure.
Uh so
that's
kind of our best tool
in reality for dealing with these
situations often. But why might it be a
mistake to assume failure?
Well, what if it's something like this?
Uh in this case so far we've just been
talking about M1 asking
for the value of X. So M1 is just asking
a question and getting an answer.
But what if it's a different kind of a
message, right?
What if it's this? Um
What if what if M1
uh actually caused a side effect
on M2. So let's say the message was like
increment X.
And then the response from M2 was okay.
So
if M2 was originally
originally had X set to five and then
this increment occurred
and now X is six.
Um so
if M1 doesn't get this okay response
uh
you don't know whether the increment
happened.
So if you get the okay response
you can assume that the increment
occurred, right? Assuming no Byzantine
faults.
But if you don't get that okay response
it would be wrong to assume that it did
occur and it would also be wrong to
assume that it didn't occur, right?
Because the failure could have been the
one where M2 sent the message back and
then
the message got lost, right? So in that
case
X could already be six over here and M1
M1 would just never get the
confirmation.
Uh so in that case if M1 sent this
message out and never got a response
uh M1 wouldn't know whether the
increment happened or not. So it's not
really safe to assume that it did or it
didn't.
And this sort of uncertainty is is a
fundamental characteristic
of distributed systems.
So although timeouts can be really
useful, right? In this case let's say
this message does get lost on the way
back from M2. So M1 has sent this
increment X message and it's set this
timeout, right?
It never gets the response and so the
timeout expires.
But that doesn't mean that M1 can assume
that the increment didn't happen because
it's also always possible that the
failure happened on the way back from
M2.
Uh so there's there's
as we'll see when we talk about more in
the course,
we're going to find that this sort of
uncertainty and this
this fundamental uncertainty that we
have
is inevitable in distributed systems and
there's there's kind of one way around
it.
Questions about that?
Uh
Somebody asked in chat what are cosmic
rays? Um
Yeah, so um
it's
There's there's a pretty good answer in
chat actually. Somebody points out
cosmic rays will cause the bits in a
machine to flip um
causing a machine to have differing
values than others in the same system
for no reason
that's
uh
kind of debuggable using the tools that
we have.
So um
So one of the biggest causes of
uncertainty in this example
is network latency, right?
And if we knew for sure that there was
some sort of maximum delay on messages
in a network, then that would allow it
us to rule out certain kinds of
failures, right? Um
Uh so for example,
let's say that you know that um
that the maximum amount of time that it
would take a message to get
from M1 to M2
um
is um
some number D.
And then let's say that the maximum And
let That's the maximum delay, let's say,
for any message in the network. So,
that's the maximum delay of a message
from M1 to M2 or from M2 to M1.
And then also, the maximum time, uh
let's say that M2 could spend processing
a request
is
let's say some number R.
So, so if that were the case, um let's
say that Let's say that the maximum
delay of a message in the network is D.
And let's say that the maximum
processing time that M2 spends
responding to a request is R.
Um So, in that case
uh what should the timeout be on M1's
end?
How long should M1 wait?
Yeah, it's it's 2D + R, right?
Because the time that it takes for the
message to get from here to here is at
most D. R is the maximum time the
message takes on this end, and then D
again is the maximum time that it takes
on this end.
So, that would rule out certain kinds of
uh of uncertainty that we had before. Um
so
it would rule out the the kinds of
uncertainty that have to do with
slowness, right? Uh so, we uh
two of the kinds of uncertainty that we
talked about were the message from M1 to
M2 just being slow, right? Or the
message from M2 to M1 being slow.
Uh so, that those would be ruled out by
that.
Um
but that still leaves a lot of kinds of
uncertainty that we still have to deal
with. Uh it still leaves the the machine
crashed scenario, and it still leaves
the possibility of the the network
connection just going out.
Um and and and furthermore, um
most of the time, we don't actually have
this this sort of guarantee about a
maximum delay.
Uh sometimes, we make a simplifying
assumptions in systems that we build,
and we we assume that there is a maximum
delay. Um but on the internet in
general, that's not actually true.
Um so
my colleague um Peter Alvaro uh likes to
say that in distributed uh we have to
deal with Not only do we have to deal
with this partial failure problem, um
but we also have to deal with unbounded
latency.
Not only that, but um
uh
Not only does he say that, but he he
actually This is actually how he defines
distributed systems.
So, this is Peter Alvaro's definition.
So, in distributed systems, we have to
deal with both partial failure and
unbounded latency, and that's what makes
it so hard.
Okay. So, we've talked about
what a distributed system is, and we've
given a couple of different definitions.
Um
what about why? Why would you want a
system like this, given how clearly
terrible they are, right? Uh given how
hard they are to de- debug and and
build, uh why would you Why would you
want a distributed system?
So, somebody in chat A couple people in
chat say scalability. What does that
mean?
So
one reason is maybe you have no choice,
right?
So, if you have more data than can even
fit on one machine
uh then you need to have a distributed
system.
Uh so, if you're Google uh you have no
choice but to do distributed computing
all day every day.
And then the other possibility is that
even if you aren't dealing with data at
that scale, um
maybe you want to make things faster.
And some sometimes, you can do that by
using more computers.
Uh so, we'll talk about that more later
on in the course as well.
Um
so, I I I'm still wondering. So, a
couple of people asked uh or a couple of
people mentioned scalability. Uh
so, so what does that mean? Well, one of
one of the things that it means is this
first point, right? Um so, scaling could
involve scaling to to to more data,
right? Uh another possibility uh
is um
uh scaling to more users, but more users
can also mean more data, right?
Uh
some other people are pointing out
things like um redundancy. Um yeah, so
this it this isn't necessarily
um
so, so redundancy doesn't necessarily
mean um
that the system has to be distributed,
right? I could have multiple copies of
something, but have them just be on one
machine. But
that doesn't necessarily help if that
machine crashes, right? Uh
if I want my redundant copies to
actually fail independently
then I need the sys- I need them to be
physically separate in some way, right?
And the more physically separate that
they are, uh
the the less likely it is that their
failure is going to be correlated. Uh
so, that's yet another reason uh why you
might want things to be distributed.
So, um
at this point, uh I want to pause and do
a quiz question.
And uh so, we'll pause for about 3
minutes, and I'll I'll put up the link
to the question in chat.
So, if you're on the class Slack, you
should see this uh quiz question coming
up. Uh the form will now automatically
collect your email address as you fill
it out.
Which means that you have to be
logged in to
uh
um
to your UCSC Google email in order to
fill it out.
Oh, some people are saying the form is
closed. Just try refreshing it.
Right, we'll give it um
a few minutes.
All right.
Over 100 responses already. I'm going to
leave it open for a little while longer.
Uh but let's move on.
So,
we started to talk about timeouts a
little bit. Uh and that kind of brings
us to our next topic, uh
which is time.
and clocks.
So,
my colleague Peter, when he's lecturing
about this, he likes to start by asking,
"What is time?"
Uh but seriously, what is time? Uh
like what do we use time for? Or or what
do we use clocks for?
Um does anybody have any like particular
suggestions about what do we use clocks
for? Uh and this doesn't even have to be
specific to distributed systems. Uh what
what do we use clocks for in computing?
Uh
to synchronize stuff is a suggestion.
So, yeah, so
we use clocks
to say when something will happen.
Right? So, that we can rendezvous.
So,
uh so one thing that clocks for are for
is to sit to mark particular points in
time.
So,
this class starts
at 9:20 a.m.
PDT.
Uh that would be an example of marking a
particular point in time.
Or
this item in my browser cache expires on
April 1st at uh 3:00 p.m.
Or this error in the log file has a
timestamp of uh
March 13th uh 11:56 a.m.
So, those are all particular points
marked in time.
Uh so that's that's one thing that
clocks are for.
Um
What else are clocks for?
So, what about timeouts, which we were
just talking about a second ago? Uh
so so timeouts uh
are for
discussing durations
or intervals of time.
So, this class
is 65 minutes long.
So, that's a an example of an interval.
Or
this request will expire in 30 seconds,
right? This request will time out in 30
seconds.
That's a timeout like we talked about.
Or this user spent 4 minutes and 9
seconds on our website. Those are all
examples of of measuring durations or
intervals of time. Uh and and both these
are pretty useful, right? Uh
So,
computers have both uh what are called
time of day clocks
and monotonic clocks. Uh so, let's talk
about the difference between those.
Um so,
so time of day clock
uh
tells you what time it is. Um it's
usually synchronized between machines uh
using NTP,
which is the network time protocol.
And time of day clocks
are bad for measuring durations or
intervals.
So, if these are the
things one and two that that clocks are
used for,
time of day clocks are bad for measuring
durations or intervals of time. Why? Why
are they bad for that?
Yeah, so clocks for one thing clocks
might not be perfectly synchronized
between machines, right? So, NTP is
pretty good. NTP stands for network time
protocol. Um
And it does a pretty good job.
Um but it's not uh
it it doesn't necessarily mean machine
that machines are are
absolutely uh synchronized. Uh but one
reason why this is bad for measuring
durations or intervals is because
the time the time of day time can
actually jump backward and forward.
Uh so,
either due to to things like daylight
savings time
uh
or for other reasons,
um
this is the number two in case you can't
read it.
Um
So,
time of day clocks are not what you want
to use for implementing timeouts.
They're not what you want to use for
implementing something that has to
measure a duration or an interval of
time.
What about timestamping particular
events?
Um
well, time of day clocks are okay-ish
for that.
Uh
but only okay and not great.
And the reason why it's only okay is
because again, clock synchronization is
only so good.
And we might need some more fine-grained
sort of resolution to prevent certain
kinds of bugs. And we'll talk more about
why that's true soon.
Um so, those are time of day clocks.
Um so,
given that time of day clocks are bad
for
durations or in over intervals of time,
and they're only okay for marking points
of time, they're not going to be the
kinds of clocks that we uh
use much in distributed computing.
Uh you can maybe get away with them some
of the time for the second for the for
for marking points in time, but if you
if you try to do that uh
uh
sooner or later you'll run into
problems.
Um so, then there's monotonic clocks.
Um so, monotonic clocks only go forward.
Um so, a monotonic clock
is going to be some kind of counter. And
maybe it counts up, let's say,
uh milliseconds uh since the machine was
restarted, right? Uh and so, if you use
Python, for example, uh
you can um
uh
if if you if you import the the time
library, uh there's uh
uh
uh there's a mechanism uh
that you can use for uh for a monotonic
counter. And if you um
if if you check what your monotonic
clock says at a given time, uh it's not
going to have anything to do with what
your neighbor has uh
uh if they check the same thing uh
because uh
its absolute value is meaningless and
not comparable between machines.
So, it doesn't help you at all in terms
of marking uh particular points in time.
It's completely useless for for
timestamping particular points.
Um so, it's bad
uh for purpose one.
But it's good for purpose two.
Because if what you need to do is
timeout after a certain number of of
milliseconds,
uh then uh
then it'll work great.
Um
yeah, so so um
so Unix timestamps are a monotonic
clock. Uh
and um
so you can you can actually do this
experiment yourself in Python if you if
you um
if you do um import time
uh and then you call uh time.monotonic
uh uh you can check and see what your uh
your monotonic clock on your machine
says.
Uh so
and I think it's just the number of
milliseconds since your uh
since your machine's been running.
So
which of these kinds of clocks are
useful in distributed systems? Uh well,
so monotonic clocks, right? Because
we can use them to implement timeouts.
And as we saw, timeouts are something
that that we often need.
Um but timeouts or or or but monotonic
clocks aren't useful for comparing
between machines.
So okay, so we've got a way to implement
timeouts and that's great. We have
monotonic clocks. By the way, if you
tried to implement monotonic or if you
tried to implement timeouts, rather,
using time of day clocks, uh you would
get into big trouble uh um
uh not only with things like uh um
uh
daylight savings time, but also with
leap seconds. Uh
so if you're curious about a fun
distributed systems bug, uh
go look up the the Cloudflare leap
second bug. What they did was they
actually tried to implement timeouts
using time of day clocks.
So
that kind of leaves us, you know, with
this question, right? So we have a way
of of measuring durations or intervals
of time that that works reasonably well
for distributed systems, but
this question of how to mark points in
time is still open, right? Uh we don't
necessarily have a good way of doing it
uh
that's uh
uh u- using these kinds of clocks. So
now is probably a good time to point out
that the kinds of clocks that I've been
talking about so far uh are what are
called physical clocks, right?
So both of these kinds of clocks, time
of day clocks and monotonic clocks, that
I've been talking about so far are
physical clocks.
In distributed systems
uh as some people in chat have already
anticipated
uh
we can't get away with just having
physical clocks. Uh
we need a different notion of clock
which is called a logical clock.
Um
so this physical clocks includes both
time of day
and monotonic clocks.
Logical clocks don't do the same thing
that that the clocks that we've just
talked about do.
Uh they don't measure time of day
and they don't measure elapsed time.
Instead they only measure the ordering
of events.
We'll discuss this idea a whole lot this
quarter.
So
this is a different notion of clock,
right?
Uh it's not
necessarily what we're used to when
we're thinking about clocks, right?
So a fundamental question when talking
about ordering of events, right? Is
which event happened before another?
And this is going to be particularly
important to know, especially when you
get into situations like we talked about
earlier
uh when we were uh when we were talking
about um
communicating between two machines and
the possibility that there might uh be
this third machine out there, right?
That might be changing the value of this
uh this variable X that we're trying to
read, right? So one thing that may we
might want to try to figure out, right?
Let's say that M1 is trying to read the
value of X from M2 and then some other
machine out there, M3, is actually
resetting
the value of X.
Well, we might want to know which
happened first, right? Did M3 change the
value of X before M1 read it?
Uh well
that's a question about ordering of an
event ordering of events. So knowing
which event happened before another is
pretty crucial to correctness in
distributed systems.
Um so this is something that we're going
to talk about a great deal uh this
quarter.
Um let's say that you have two events,
right?
Say A and B.
Um and they could be anything. They
could be anything at all. Um but yeah,
we we could say they're like database
rights.
Um but they could be anything.
And
so let's say we have
A and B.
And let's suppose that I know that A
happened before B.
The notation that we're going to use for
that is
A arrow B.
So we'll write A arrow B like this uh
when we know that A happened before B.
Um we'll talk about ways to know that A
happened before B uh
sooner or later.
Um but
what does it tell me uh
if I know that A happened before B
um
what does that tell me about causality?
What does that tell me about what could
have caused what?
So there's a couple things you know,
right?
So if A happened before B
we know that A could
have caused B, right?
We don't know for sure that A caused B.
But we know it could have, right?
What else do we know?
We know that B could not
have caused A.
So Peter Alvaro taught this course in
fall 2018
and I'm teaching it now. His style of
teaching could have influenced mine.
Spoiler, it did.
Um
but my style of teaching right now
could not at this very moment uh
could not have been an influence on the
way that he taught CSE 30 yesterday.
Um or on Monday. So
could what I'm doing now influence
something that he does in the future?
Potentially, yes.
Um so this notion of of causality or
potential causality uh
in this case
that A could have caused B and B could
not have caused A.
Um this is very important in distributed
systems.
Um why?
Why is it so important?
Sure, debugging. So yeah, one way that
it can help us is debugging.
Um so let's say that I'm looking at my
distributed system and I have some sort
of bug, right? Um let's say that one
machine thinks X equals 1 and one
machine thinks X equals 5.
It's helpful at that point to be able to
look back at all of the events that
occurred and try to figure out what may
have caused X to be 1 or what may have
caused X to be 5, right?
And this notion of happens before
won't answer all our questions, but it
will at least allow us to rule out some
things that definitely did not cause the
bug.
Um so things this is good for
one is debugging.
Right?
Uh so figuring out
possible causes of a bug.
Uh what else is it good for?
So I would say that it's useful in
designing systems in the first place.
So if you can design a system
such that
if you know that event A happened before
B
then your system will never allow users
to observe event B before event A.
It's possible to design a system that
way. And we'll talk a lot more about
this soon.
So that's it for today.
Uh we'll come back next time and we're
going to talk a lot more about this
notion of happened before and we'll
begin to introduce some more concepts.
Uh
for those of you who are in the class uh
at UCSC and not just watching on Twitch
uh
I have office hours after this.
So
see you later.